while amazing how we work ourselves up
so much with increasing the standard of
living that we forget to increase the
standard of my life I don't want you to
have to suffer the same thing that I
suffered through my purpose comes from
my pain and so does yours
let's not make happiness and success
about the size of our homes but about
the size of our heart rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day off right together grab
your copy and sip on today's message
increase the standard of your life over
you go or gopaldas also if you want to
know agora Gopal das and others have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confident series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below and it's easy to make
a buck very hard to make a difference
[Music]
whether you drive a fox wagon or you
drive a Bentley the road remains the
same isn't it whether you speak on a
Samsung or you speak on an iPhone X
whoever your scolding remains the same
whether you're flying economy or you're
flying business the destination area
heading remains the same isn't it
whether you're wearing a simple fast
track all you wear an Omega or a Rolex
the time remains
it's quite amazing how we work ourselves
up so much with increasing the standard
of living that we forget to increase the
standard of our life and which is why
wherever I travel I make an appeal to
people there's nothing wrong with an
Omega and nothing wrong with a Bentley
god bless you with that and if you have
it drive at no problem but it is trying
to enhance and increase and improvise
the standard of your living please
please do not compromise with the
standard of your life it's not the
standard of your living that makes you
happy it is a standard of your life that
makes me happy and very often we forget
to give attention to those things that
can truly make us happy which is why I
always say things that I'm talking about
they have utility value right not
happiness value travel business rather
first-class travel no problem Drive
apparently no problem but in doing so
never ever compromise on those
principles that also improve the
standard of your life and therefore I
always say some people are so poor so
poor so absolutely for that all they
have is money that's all that's all
I consider that life a power district in
life if all you have is money you're the
poorest person in the world because
there's more to life than money and
there's way more to life than what money
can buy and therefore a many times say
if you want to truly know how rich you
are drop it here and see how many hands
come forth to wipe that deal ladies and
gentlemen a happiness a happiness and I
increased standard of life is not in
things it's in people it's relationships
it's meaningful heartfelt deep bondings
of love that bring fulfillment to the
heart it was meaningful exchanges of
love that we share with each other and
relationships that brings true joy to
the heart and isn't it the greatest
irony it's something that brings in the
greatest fulfillment be very
conveniently neglected in just running
after increasing and enhancing a
standard of living people are built to
serve if you are not happy in your life
it's because you are not serving enough
99.99% of people are built to serve the
ones that don't have a few screws loose
up in their head they are built to serve
and if you don't figure out how you can
serve people you will never be happy no
matter how much money you make no matter
how much success you get if you cannot
figure out how you can be of service to
people you will never be happy in your
life ok so the next question becomes how
do I figure out how to serve other
people I think people are grouped in the
two categories one are the people who
want to serve the world the people who
want to grow and have a big impact want
to touch millions and millions of lives
that's what I want to do I want to serve
the world and others they want to serve
the 20 closest people to them their
closest friends our closest family they
don't have an ambition to serve the
world but they want to serve those
closest to them first figure out who you
want to serve next you figure out how
you're gonna serve them and so I'm a big
believer that your purpose comes from
your pain that your purpose the thing
that you want to do most the way that
you can serve and give back the most to
others to the world or to those closest
people to you is through your
Payne when did you feel the most pain in
your life when did you feel the most
worthless as a human being ever in your
life and then how can you help others
who are going through those same
situations right now think about that
most painful moment it's tough I know
you don't want to go there I know as
entrepreneurs are always thinking
positive and optimistic but I need you
to go there right now I need you to
think about that moment right now that
moment that you never want anybody else
in the world to have to go through that
is the path through which you are
ultimately going to be able to serve
others and so if I think for me as much
as I love entrepreneurs and I think
we're gonna solve all the world's major
problems and I think entrepreneurship is
the answer we're not gonna rely on
corporations we're not gonna rely on
governments to fix problems it's us we
will do it
that leans heavily on the positive the
real reason why I do what I do is
because I struggle so much as an
entrepreneur myself because I felt
worthless I remember I remember quitting
on my business partner I remember
telling him I'm out I feel like a
terrible human being and I feel like I
bring no value I've been putting all my
effort into making this business happen
and we're getting no results like it's
not working it's not happening I need to
feel like I'm a worthwhile human being
like I can apply my efforts on something
and start seeing some results and so
because I felt so crappy about myself in
those moments I never want other people
to have to go through that and that's
really at the core of why I do what I do
of why I make these videos of why I
spend hours at conferences and workshops
tane until crazy hours in the morning
helping because I don't want you to have
to suffer the same thing that I suffered
through my purpose comes from my pain
and so it is yours so just remember that
you are built to serve that you are
built to serve that if you are not happy
it's because you are not serving the
people around you enough either on a
mass scale serving the world having a
big impact or the 20 people closest to
you you are built to serve and the way
to serve them is through your pain when
you feel the most worthless helping
other people along their journey so they
never have to face what you've faced and
if you're not willing to go there if
you're not willing to figure that out if
you're not willing to put on that hat of
service then you'll never be happy
and no matter how much money you chase
down and no matter how much success you
have an Omaha any accolades that people
throw on you you will never be happy
because you are not serving and so I
hope you find it because through service
you will increase the standard of your
life now I've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know do you want to serve the world
or the twenty closest people to you let
me know down in the comments below
we need to define what success means for
us we need to redefine what success
means let's not make happiness and
success about the size of our homes but
about the size of our heart let's not
make it about gratification but
gratitude we speak about being healthy
and our well being but we act more like
human doings than we do like human
beings and therefore instead of to-do
list we need to be list
instead of completing about what you
want to do think about who you want to
be do you want to be more self-aware do
you want to be more conscious even to be
a better person do you want to be a
difference in the world we need to move
away from what we want to do in
situations to really want to be in
situations the three most common things
that we forget when we're rushing out of
our homes is our keys our wallet or our
mobile phone and it's absolutely
hilarious how you run back inside you
look in all your drawers you look in
your desk you make a mess sometimes and
then how many times have you had it that
you realize it was actually in your back
pocket sometimes even in your hand and
it's funny that our experience of
happiness is so similar to this we run
around trying to find it in absolutely
every place but actually when we come
back home we find out that it's within
raise your standard its core value not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's something serene if you want
more Google pal das check out the video
I made on his five pieces of
life-changing advice the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I always say some people are so
poor so poor that all they have is money